[Musique]
l'une est terminée depuis longtemps
l'autre débute à peine mais les deux
enquêtes sont toutes aussi
spectaculaires et marquante dans
l'histoire politique des états unis
première similitude le rôle des lanceurs
d'alert cambriolage au parti démocrate
de titre le washington post du dimanche
18 juin 1972 en apparence un fait divers
presque banale ni de nouilles ou non
mais dans les jours qui suivent un
mystérieux personnages entrent en scène
il fournit à des reporters du quotidien
des informations compromettantes tels
que le racontait le film les hommes du
président quelques années plus tard des
informations qui permettent d'établir
progressivement l'implication du
président lexus et son entourage
le lanceur d'alert surnommé gorge
profonde était en fait le directeur
adjoint du fbi haye un homme crédible et
puissant a thing y aura des nombreux
projets en 2019
l'histoire ukrainienne est révélée par
un lanceur d' alerte anonyme
on sait qu'il travaille à la cia y est
il a été informé d'une conversation
téléphonique litigieuse entre le
président trump et son vis-à-vis
ukrainien
volodymyr zelensky au sujet du démocrate
joe biden et de son fils trentenaire est
bien dévoiler l'identité de cet
informateur qu'ils considèrent comme un
traître
les élus rappellent le président à
l'ordre l'identité du lanceur d' alerte
est formellement protégé par une loi
adoptée en 1998
c'est confirmé un deuxième lanceur
d'alert membres des services de
renseignement américain est prêt à
témoigner dans laquelle un deuxième un
formateur s'est aussi manifestée il
serait lui un témoin direct de cette
conversation entre 30 et zelensky
[Musique]
de 1972 à 1974
le président richard nixon nitoo
l'espionnage le camouflage des faits la
caisse noire de son comité électoral le
paiement de sommes colossales pour
acheter le silence de témoins jusqu'à ce
que l'épreuve le contredisent
aujourd'hui dans notre hub ni aussi et
se dit victime de la plus importante
chasse aux sorcières de toute l'histoire
des états unis
et il attaque la maison blanche refuse
de collaborer à l'enquêté du congrès est
interdit à ses employés de témoigner les
démocrates parle d' entrave à la justice
et ils sont les grands bras de fer
juridique est engagée
[Musique]
autre similitude entre nixon et rompent
leurs relations pour le moins tendues
avec la presse
manifestement le président nixon
n'appréciait pas beaucoup la couverture
médiatique dont il faisait l'objet
[Applaudissements]
on n'a rien inventé
richard nixon avait dit que cette
histoire de watergate n'aurait eu aucune
importance sans tous ces journalistes
qui le détestaient d'un autre homme
s'énerve contre les médias qu'il
qualifie de bidons encore plus depuis le
début de l' enquête
il dispose par contre d'un outil de
communication directe que l'autre
n'avait pas et qu'ils utilisent
abondamment pour plaider sa cause
[Musique]
le bureau ovale de richmond exxon et est
farcie de microphones le président
enregistré toutes ses rencontres et ses
conversations téléphoniques dans le but
d'écrire un jour ses mémoires
un véritable trésor pour la commission
denquête au congrès
c'est la preuve irréfutable on découvre
que le président nixon était impliqué à
fond dans le camouflage des activités
illégales commises par ses organisateurs
politiques on l'entend clairement
participé à des magouilles de type
mafieuse les électeurs et les élus
républicains le lâche à chaud les gens à
ne pas respecter notamment pour éviter
l'humiliation nixon quitte son poste
avant la tenue d'un vote sur sa
destitution dont l'issue ne fait plus
aucun doute
les démocrates croient détenir cette
fois encore une preuve accablante avec
le contenu de la conversation
m
les démocrates doivent démontrer que le
président trump a exercé une forme de
chantage en liant le versement d'une
aide financière des états unis à une
promesse d' enquêtes des ukrainiens
contre joe biden et son fils
des enregistrements officiels de cette
conversation existe le fameux smoking
gun pourrait se trouver là ou encore
dans les témoignages de proches
collaborateurs du président trump qui
sont actuellement entendus à huis clos
au congrès